tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video sono Favij e vedere sono
vestito proprio elegante per uscire oggi
sono qua perché giocherò ad un gioco che
simula un po' i neuroni che scopriremo
se li abbiamo meno e per scoprirlo ho
bisogno anche dei miei compagni di oggi
perché non farò questo video solo oggi
ci sono anche delle persone mi
accompagnano perché in questo gioco che
si chiama Big Brain Academy sfida tra 20
mesi deve stirare tra Menfi e siccome io
adesso non lo so lo vediamo di inserire
altrimenti facciamo entrare il primo
ospite di oggi che è il grandissimo
Ermanno Perfetto Ciao Ermanno 26 anni
come me che gli abbiamo un'età non ha
iniziato a 25 25 anni domani che
facciamo entrare un'altra persona che
conoscete molto bene 321 Benvenuto
Lorenzo
terza in un film
[Musica]
importanza
321 Benvenuto Jacopo
[Risate]
[Applauso]
appunto ragazzi la modalità individuale
e la modalità party da quando ha 4
giocatori e mettiamo 4 siamo pronti Oh
che
bello Favij
[Applauso]
gira gira la ruota scelta della materia
cosa facciamo
Gira la ruota a ruota quello che esce
Faccio anche
la differenza Io che ti dico
di difficoltà che possiamo scegliere
Perché ognuno può scegliere il suo
ovviamente Gabri per bambini
per me gli altri guardano milioni di
persone da almeno una figura barbina
insieme
Vito io per primo
non lo so non lo so non lo so
[Musica]
Ma io sono
come ti pare cliccare sulla Dai non lo
sapevo
il giocatore come gioca come gioca come
gioca il Paris perciò
essere anche quello è effettivamente
il terzo è
tutta l'altra parte vorrei Mori da lampo
da perdere
al gioco
[Musica]
96 è con 4 cifre dai
insieme però dai Forse mi porti ancora
Cioè tu come hai fatto a fare due cifre
Ragazzi allora adesso visto che il
vincitore Proviamo a vedere se il mio
cervello è così si può giocare
individuale anche on-line per infatti
abbiamo fatto prima Adesso andiamo a
individuare letto
[Applauso]
faccio sempre a
Matteo Ma non c'entra niente
e metteresti in consigliato di fare
esame però se vuoi prepararti lo
stretching
a casalinga anche colta c'è
riflessi incredibili più che quello che
lavora poi alla fine lui e li
ho visti
[Musica]
sbagliato
Adesso voglio vedere
il coso
capito che mi avrebbe fatto Lorenzo per
i
piatti li schiaccio di là
ho
capito Devo fare
i blocchi per farlo diventare come su
proprio blocco
[Musica]
Ah ok Ah ok Com'è fatto lo scherzo
sta facendo
Grillo
espressi col punteggio Cervellone
[Musica]
per una persona che non avrebbe fatto
molto
quindi io ho la mandi io cioè certo
cervellone eh
signori signori senza
mai preso un otto in si chiama tua mamma
chiama tua mamma
avete disponibile Se volete anche la
demo on-line del gioco che è gratuita
Quindi provatelo Ragazzi io ho fatto 22
99 legge per venire però
Adesso piano piano piano Ma fatemi
sapere quanto fate anche perché se mi
taggano su Instagram la storia di più
quindi non c'era nessuno quindi ragazzi
però che sei bella
Lorenzino bellissimissimissimissimi che
fai tu
vediamo proprio video e chiedere come mi
piace come ti avevo detto
niente
sulla spalla che vabbè ma
[Risate]
Ciao ragazze
[Musica]